mudassir open image of the old departed
the skimmer ebay leaders MTG dama visa
today no fear no fear agt but you see
professor ok I'm ok Sasha sweater
persona this is Geraldine story we can't
give you her real name or tell you where
she lives after fleeing decades of abuse
which left her disabled and unable to
work she is slowly piecing her life back
together with the help of an NGO who are
on a house call but Geraldine's life is
still very much a struggle so ya du jour
je ne mojesh look at that the result
what is it Shuang couche pas pris kindle
food medicham Oh told on me but even
without enough money to eat she has
helped which in itself makes her luckier
than most women the simple fact of being
born a woman puts you at an instant
disadvantage seventeen percent of women
compared a sixteen percent of men in the
EU are at a risk from poverty and social
exclusion taniyama sucheta dalaman
situatio meses affair high tea private
Kelly mean even more deep aqua me Loomis
two o'clock el puente la mancha Hitler
Bertha the European Parliament is
pushing for new ideas to help women in
poverty they want changes that can help
create a better balance between work and
family life figures show that
thirty-four percent of single mothers
are at a greater risk of poverty vs.
seventeen percent of those with a family
structure another idea is to make basic
essentials more affordable for those on
the breadline
I